alors entretien à la chaîne pour ce
jeune homme
munis de leur cv lycéens étudiants ou
encore demandeurs d'emploi sont partis
mardi à la rencontre des entreprises de
la région sous le chapiteau du forum
jobs d'été à versailles
j'ai déjà fait pas mal de demandes sur
internet il n'y a pas trop de réponses
donc je préfère me déplacer pour avoir
il pourra voir des choses concrètes en
fait parce qu'internet ça marche pas
tout le temps ouais y'a pas mal de
fautes ou chercher puis après c'est
d'avoir un rendez vous mais il ya quand
même pas mal de monde donc et si la
concurrence est rude c'est aussi parce
que la crise est passée par là et fait
la crise très certainement en fait c'est
vrai que certains qui recrutait beaucoup
plus l'été maintenant vont s'arranger
entre collet pour pour moi recruter de
jeunes l'été donc forcément ça joue si
si la crise est la crise est passée par
là
au total seuls quatre entreprises
étaient finalement présente dans le
domaine de l'accueil de l'aide à la
personne et de l'intérim en btp
pour eux pas question d'être absent
aujourd'hui puisqu'il faut toujours
remplacer les employés qui partent en
vacances hôtes et hôtesses d'accueil
pour cette entreprise par exemple
non on a toujours des besoins non au
contraire on a beaucoup d'offres nous a
proposé nouveauté cette année le forum
s'ouvre à l'europe chantiers
internationaux volontariat mais aussi
vrai petit boulot à la clé oui il ya une
demande importante des jeunes notamment
pour partir trouver un job d'été au
royaume uni ou en irlande mais également
pour trouver du volontariat
à l'étranger et puis
pour étudier aussi dans d'autres pays
savoir comment s'y prendre quand on veut
faire un stage également dans un autre
payer certains organismes proposent des
bourses à l'emploi pour financer le
voyage à l'étranger
une manière d'inciter aux expériences
hors de l'hexagone